mecca godzilla has taken the internet by
storm
this main villain from the movie
godzilla vs kong
is now considered one of the most
powerful titans in the monsterverse
if not the most powerful but maybe
because of circumstances and that
other more powerful talents and ones
with advantages over it
had been already killed before the
events of the movie
they may not be as physically powerful
as the titan mecha
but if they went on face to face they
may be able to stop it by other means
so in this video we will list down the
three titans that can take down the
mecca
and we will tell you why but before we
go deeper into this video do remember to
click that subscribe button to be a part
of the mind cue family
so now let's get down with the sickness
firstly let's introduce mecha godzilla
and his specs along with his size and
why it was made
in 2014 godzilla made himself known to
the world and in 2019 in king of the
monsters humanity was beaten down
by many of the titans super species that
were awoken by monster zero following
his battle with godzilla off the coast
of mexico
the fact that mankind was relatively
powerless in the face of these titans
did not go unnoticed
despite the fact that godzilla had
proven to be a savior
others didn't really think so apex
industries under walter simmons set out
to dethrone him and restore humanity as
the world's dominant power
therefore mechagodzilla was constructed
standing 450 to 460 feet tall this titan
mecca was
monstrous and terrifying from the back
of his neck to the tip of the tail
he wears a set of metal plates that
resemble godzilla's dorsal plates
now with that out of the way here are
the three titans that would be able to
take down mecha g
number one the mirrors from 2014 well
if you are wondering why these two
tyrants
well the main reason is that they have
one kind of power that no other titan
does
a power that was developed to power down
godzilla's atomic breath
and that is the emp and if you know
anything about this
it's that the electromagnetic pulse can
shut down anything that is powered by
electricity
which includes humanity's weapons of war
and the mechanized titan
is mostly constructed of components that
run on electricity
it might have required the power source
from the hollow earth to power it
but the energy is converted to
electricity to make its component
functional
this was pointed out by one of our
viewers shea bishop
and he said i'm a viewer of your channel
and i've been watching your godzilla
versus kong videos and i have been
wondering a lot recently and wouldn't a
muto just be able to amp
the mechagodzilla well thanks for the
heads up shay bishop and you are
absolutely right
demeters would be very lethal against
mecha godzilla specifically for this
reason
during the movie george valentine put
whiskey onto mecha godzilla's control
panel
which resulted in him seizing up during
combat allowing kong and godzilla to
gain the upper hand
this shows that his control panels are
extremely vulnerable
which can be completely shut down by an
emp burst from one of the murals
leaving it malfunctioning and exposed
number two the muto prime well we have
decided to include this one aside from
the other two murals in the sense that
it is so
different and possesses unique powers on
its own besides an even more powerful
emp
burst that it can use against to make a
godzilla
during the fight with mechagodzilla the
director adam wingard specifically
commented that the fight would have been
so different
if godzilla hadn't been so exhausted
after the battle with kong
which means that at the most a godzilla
fresh from the oven
would have been at par with the mecca
but that didn't really fit the storyline
so it was changed
muto prime was one of the only tariffs
that was able to physically overpower
godzilla
and might be able to do the same with
mechagodzilla as well
given one or two emp bursts to slow down
mechagodzilla
a sonic roar to disturb it and a hell of
a beating
from those earthquake arms and there we
have it muter prime the winner
and lastly the third island that can
defeat mechagodzilla is no other than
godzilla himself but he would require a
drastic transformation for it to happen
a super saiyan transformation if you
will and that happened in king of the
monsters
you know what i'm talking about burning
godzilla baby
in this form godzilla was more powerful
and extremely durable to an extent that
the gravity beams
from ghidorah did absolutely nothing
despite monster zero being fully powered
at that time
and the nuclear pulse was able to melt
everything within a radius of a couple
of miles
mechagodzilla even though it was made
from unique metal alloys
wouldn't have survived a couple of these
thermonuclear pulses
if you went face to face with burning
godzilla and so with that we come to the
end of the video
do like for support and hit that
subscribe button to be a part of the
minecube family
and also smash that notification bell
for regular updates on new monsterverse
content
godzilla vs call of duty section videos
gvk kingdom kong and godzilla dominion
content
and as well take care fam